[Music]
45 seconds of Disney and Pixar basically
sixty-nining each other
oh Andy's toy based daydreams got a
budget increase no um didn't Pixar miss
a golden opportunity here to put the car
shape Bluffs from cars in the background
of the scene even if this is in some
kids imagination Jesse and bullseye were
nowhere near the back of this train in
order to save woody take that
imagination also all Toy Story movies
must open with the fantasy sequence the
first one had Woody's Old West
adventures the second had the t-rex
playing the videogame that was
supposedly real for a few minutes and
this one has this that's what you call
the formula kids Andy imagines an ex
machina for the train falling off the
cliff and later grows up to write
Hollywood screenplays I brought my
attack dog with a built-in forcefield
I brought my dinosaur who eats
forcefield dogs Andy's imagination has
improved greatly but he still does the
old forcefield dog dinosaur who eats the
forcefield dogs routine cartoon
found-footage I would make fun of Andy
setting up all his toys to watch a movie
but then I remember laying out all my
baseball cards as a kid while watching a
baseball game and I'd sub in the right
card when the manager made a roster
change and goddamn I miss being a kid
Peele movie for making me miss being a
kid even in a young Andy era depicted by
this video I still can't believe he's
still in hammered with his Woody doll
woody was practically replaced in the
first movie by Buzz Lightyear but
because of some bullshit he suddenly
gets equal billing in Andy's mind then
why did you take it out in the first
place also didn't previous movie show us
your organs still work even when not
attached so why not just look through
that eye to figure out where it is he's
17 and still has a gigantic toy chest
prominently featured in his room let's
face it the trash bags come out the army
guys are the first to go so many
thoughts sprung up here first off the
army guys have a network of other army
guys where they know they're the first
to go when it's time to clean up toys
second off there are only three army
guys here so they've apparently left the
hundreds of other army guys to be
tracked third off they do this despite a
decent chance of getting seen fourth I
guess they just knock around people's
houses until they find a bunch of other
army guys to hang with oh we've lost
friends along the way
Weezy and H and Bo Peep I guess these
toys weren't worth having an adventure
for also Holi movie hints at an even
darker Toy Story three storyline
regarding the fate of Bo Peep but then
it passes it by like it's no big deal
and
guys from the Christmas decorations box
they're fun right
how many inanimate objects come to life
in this world Christmas decorations are
they infused with a life of toys come on
let's see how much we're going for any
big you two not much is my guess
also it's 2010 so thinking obey is the
ultimate online after market sales
destination at this point is just living
in the past Andy who is an asshole eat
this Apple and lift it on a plate on his
dresser the first thing that I noticed
here is that these concert tickets are
dated 2009 which is 14 years after the
original Toy Story which means Andy
should be 20 years old at this point not
17 unless Toy Story was set in the
future ISM also you might remember that
November 17 2009 was a Tuesday like I do
because I have that kind of calendar
memory also I googled it you know just
to make sure nice memory exposition
board but um this letter here is
addressed to State University which
means Andy has not yet applied for
college that classic Toy Story decision
will Andy pick buzz or woody and to my
amazement it's woody you can't breathe
in the toy chest I guess and what
happens if you can't breathe for too
long
do you finally become a real toy and
this entire movies events happen because
this one American home has an
exceptionally spring a pull down attic
door do I have that right
Jesus Andy clearly wanted to save all
the toys but thanks to construction work
we have an adventure to watch first what
are the odds that the garbage truck is
three fuckin houses away right at this
moment
astronomical you say boy not only are
the toys strong enough to puncture this
bag with a toy dinosaur tail but they're
able to make a big enough hole without
being seen in world record time so that
they can escape luckily the guy at
picking up the garbage has both
sunglasses and headphones on for maximum
obliviousness
and that should end this little
adventure this should have been a pixar
short that ended right here
unfortunately some total bullshit is
about to happen to allow the rest of
this movie to take place there's no time
to be hysterical it's the perfect time
to be hysterical keep playing the hits
boys yeah I know it looks bad but guys
you gotta believe me they should but
they don't it's crazy how many license
plates in this world have a 1:39
that's gotta make the cops job harder
and the DMV's job the easiest ever okay
I'm going to ignore the blatant sexism
and having a Barbie doll meltdown like
Sharon Stone and Casino and focus on the
fact that it was clearly not Molly's
preference to get rid of any toys but
her mom commanded it Disney utterly
breaks mice in writing brain with a shot
that contains over 1200 unique details
to scrutinize and I'm just gonna call
this Disney one cinemasins zero and move
on well hello there big purple bear with
a cane Telegraph's this toys evilness in
the first second know about me I'm a
hugger this is exactly what Uncle Henry
said to me just before he took me out
behind the hey it's that a purple
dinosaur maybe Andy doesn't care about
us anymore this movie gets so much
mileage out of that upstairs hallway
trash bag misunderstanding he was
putting you in the Attic
I saw you can't just all toys disregard
or flat-out don't hear this statement at
this point doesn't woody deserve the
benefit of the doubt bullseye now you
need to stay after that big speech about
leaving woody and see no man's bullseye
this what floor sign says no running
which makes me think that there was a
period however brief at the wet floor
sign factory when the workers went on a
passive strike creating signs that said
things like no running stop drop and
roll and I'm on strike
[Music]
what are you ratatouille is his way out
of the situation yes he's never been
here before but basic looking where
you're goin could have avoided this
almost fall off the edge moment for
woody would he somehow assumes he has to
cross this entire playground to escape
and never once considers just running to
his left to the edge of the roof which
is clearly much closer to the wall
stupid woody luckily what he's had is
blown by the breeze straight into the
kite ex machina that he will use to get
off this roof of course no one sees this
how many films can claim win is an
actual antagonist like this one twister
I guess right old happening thankfully
for woody in this film's plot a
three-year-old girl happened to be
walking right here at this moment all by
herself
in the end though is this any different
from what Andy to do these toys when he
was filming the Train Robbery sequence
in his head he put those toys through
hell right but this is supposed to be
worse also I'll admit this toddler
Stampede is hilarious but the fact that
none of these world wise toys who lived
with a toddler for years picked up on
the fact that daycare might not be so
awesome
are you classically trained there a
situation where one of these toys broke
character even in the first movie buzz
as deluded as he was didn't break
character and what he only did it in an
emergency to that evil kid sit who's a
serial killer now are we supposed to
believe that a daycare leaves all the
toys lying around like this at the end
of the day thanks for that imagery Pixar
did anyone notice the transom why is it
open nobody knows yes he's a toy but
I've played with pipe cleaners before
and they are not suitable restraints
especially when the toys are sentient if
they oh my George taking a toy stores
name in vain while hacking up space
balls reference
I'll go get my friends whoa whoa hold on
specifically requested that he and his
friends moved to the cool kids room and
Lotso said request granite it's
impossible he didn't hear the specifics
of the request but you got a pad your
features run time somehow there's a Buzz
Lightyear instruction manual just lying
around in the library of it day care to
its original factory setting no slide
the switch
I am oh why would there be such a switch
on the back of an action figure what can
you add to a buzz lightyear that would
require you to go back to demo mode and
why does it make a difference for this
toy and everything he's learned but
these features made no difference in a
world where Christmas decorations
apparently come to life
[Music]
it's just now letting you see Andy's
room that's amazing so none of their
time while you've been gone have you
seen Andy's room until now hmm great
timing for this eye to suddenly work so
that the toys that thought they were
being thrown away know that they were
actually being loved by Andy after all
so takes off her mouth to stop her from
yelling hilarious but last movie and
this movie showed her eyes and ears work
even when detached so why aren't these
lips in his hands still bitching out lot
so when buzzes factory setting was
introduced to Andy's toys in the first
movie he was combative his help but in
this movie returning him to factory
setting makes him programmable
uncontrollable this feels like an
overabundance of clothes baskets that
the evil toys can use for daycare prison
did he get that well he left it outside
remember and who at this messy-ass
daycare would have noticed it and
actually put it back inside or else this
suggests someone on Lazos evil team
managed to get outside the daycare walls
to grab this hat here by the rope these
toys now know how to use google maps
because of course it is ruled by an evil
bear who smells of strawberries
shouldn't he smell like strawberries and
at least a little bit daycare
Daisy loved us all let me guess this
ends with Daisy either losing or giving
away her toys much like what happened to
Jesse and Toy Story 2 only this time
without a song I mean all these toys
have pretty much the same stories that
keep leading us to the same kind of
movies also ain't it great what do you
found a home where one of the toys that
broke out of Sunnyside used to hang with
lots oh and this backstory is going to
be important to this movie's plot these
parents left behind three toys when they
put their daughter in the backseat three
huge easily seen toys marked by their
daughter as her favorites and they
seemed like such loving parents it took
forever but we finally made it back to
Daisy's homeward bound the incredible
toy travels cast-off
unloved unwanted and riding on the back
of a pizza truck from the first Toy
Story nothing but sand in a couple of
Lincoln Logs
Lincoln mugs Pixar steals the gross poop
joke from DreamWorks Shrek movies
between the Toy Story films and the
finding films it's pretty obvious the
bulk of Pixar writers and animators
think children are demons there's only
one way to leave this place
poor fella trash truck comes at dawn
then it's off to the dump so we can that
do I not wake up like every other toy
and simply get out of that trash or
escape the trash truck you know if it
were what he would the monkeys the eye
in the sky he sees everything classroom
except when buzz broke out earlier
monkey totally didn't see that in fact
it took buzz running into the big baby
in the attic of that snack machine for
the evil toys to even notice he was gone
oops you forgot that didn't you even the
playground yeah but these toys managed
to get past all that other security
before they stupidly tried to openly
scale the wall so either this monkey is
terrible at his job or the cautious toys
trying to make their escape decided to
be careless at the most crucial time
this monkey sees everything unless he's
being distracted by mr. Potato Head who
has already been cornered by the other
employees of Lotso security detail wait
a minute was this always here or did
woody cut this out seems like it mr.
Potato Head knew this was here his first
night in the Box wouldn't gone so bad
somehow Toy Story 3 found room for a
changing outfit montage like we're
watching mrs. Doubtfire Dumb and Dumber
the tortilla as in a tortilla you knew
about before this plan started how did
you know it was in this lunchbox
carelessly left behind by a toddler
anyway still can't believe the best idea
they had was for Potato Head to plug
this into a tortilla as opposed to oh I
don't know
molded glob of play-doh or something
they basically rewrote all the rules of
the potato head family to make this
movie work luckily they did this on a
night with a full moon I don't know why
this couldn't wait until morning Ken
Barbie dresses up like astronaut Ken to
fool the bookworm but how did she ask
for the Buzz Lightyear manual without
sounding like Barbie doing a bad Ken
impression Yakko dice bathia holding the
Buzz Lightyear reset button for more
than five seconds turns him into a
Antonio Banderas
we got to switch him back
farts in Spanish this is actually
becoming infuriating how would you know
those particular directions are in
Spanish and why would an instruction
manual with English and Spanish
instructions only have instructions for
changing him back in Spanish and
wouldn't there be a picture somewhere if
you ever find yourself wondering how
this third movie in a series is an hour
and forty-five minutes long
look no further than this scene here no
I'm sorry cowboy they broke me fine but
you did not know their entire plan or
their exact up to the second location
did you also how did they know to
torture this asshole they would have had
to know something was already going down
before going to him and torturing him
right big baby would be excellent at
cinema since the needs of the one oh god
damn it the needs of the many outweigh
okay did that happen the dumpster door
was completely closed when they started
running across it now he's stuck in the
door
come on and of course that's the way the
Ned Beatty bear gets woody into the
dumpster
toys have the power to lift giant TVs up
just wanted to let you guys know that
[Music]
you better come take a look at this
cliche it's not a Pixar movie unless the
heroes are on some sort of giant
conveyor belt of death despite Lotso
being basically the devil woody will
still feel compelled to try and save him
ultimately endangering the lives of
everyone else in the process hashtag
just let Lotso die sure and that's what
you get for trusting a dude that has
been nothing but a 100% asshole dick
face this entire movie Mount Doom
literal fires of hell make this
children's movie darkest I have at least
one niece that is scarred for life
thanks to this movie Wow ex machina also
yep those three somehow separated from
the main group then overpowered the
humans in this claw control room then
figured out the claw controls in a
matter of seconds also how the fuck does
this large ask loss I'm he'll pick up
every single toy in danger without a
single one slipping through the gate
like I really care sure this romance
began when he was in Spanish mode but
still drank all toys should be doing it
movie couldn't just let Lotso get away
with it he had to be found by a garbage
guy who actually love this toy as a kid
but somehow is inexplicably punished by
being hung up on a truck grille for some
reason geez how long does it take for
this asshole to pack
[Music]
and he doesn't even remotely question
why the toys he knows he threw into a
garbage bag and he knows his mom took to
the curb are now here neatly in a box
waiting to be sent to the new kid
and so we're assholes this ending is
extremely touching might even make you
cry I'm just gonna remove five sins and
be done with it
but also when I was Andy's age I sold
all my transformers toys and a garage
sale so I could pass them on and grow up
then I regretted it hard like I might
have cried about it once or twice my
freshman year in college during the
really lonely nights kind of hard and by
me I mean some other loser who cries
over toys that it's definitely not me
sorry Optimus Zerg sits out the entire
third movie and somehow I'm supposed to
be satisfied because he's ending up at
the Guantanamo Bay daycare prison is no
fairytale world ever since cinemasins
began the most requested thing has been
TV since and now it's a reality click
the link in the description below to
check it out and now the audio outtakes
that's what I love about these high
school girls man I get older they stay
the same
[Music]
I'm Batman Barbie